[Music]
very early I remember being in my
backyard and speaking with Suzanne
Collins and when we were talking about
the book ballad and it was in that call
that she actually said that there's a
huge musical element to the story that
sort of comes from the old ballads from
Scotland and England and
Ireland
midnight in a
Hanging Tree
and so we hired a great music producer
and songwriter uh Dave Cobb and he and
Suzanne had long talks about like the
history and the sort of references for
each of the songs that she had written
Suzanne Collins tells me every single
detail and the feel and the sound the
inspiration for the song so it's going
to be fun to take all this history of
maybe British is music and southern
music and mash it all together in this
dystopian way in this future and kind of
keep it raw and rugged and fine a sound
that isn't a sound that's been had
before you
know take my
history you could take my
P but his
[Music]
name so it's casting the right players
I'm having this incredible group of
people come down and play on it the
artist that he works with and assembled
for these sessions the music he composed
the way that it really fits suzan's
lyrics every song as we would hear the
demos they stay with you they're so
specific there's not any two songs that
you mix up with the other
come when I got all of the scratch
recordings for the music I just fell in
love and was like we got we got this
part right for sure I really admire the
songs Dave contributed there's certainly
a rural aspect to The District 12 music
and I think that's been in there from
the very beginning and so to me it was
just consistent extension of what we
were stylistically trying to
[Music]
achieve in a lot of ways this is really
the first time they've had a a singing
character like this and I think that's
going to be the fun part of the film is
discovering the sound of Lucy gr take my
CH can't take my humor you can take my
way
it's
just singing for her and this is where
we really got lucky not only could she
do the sort of pre-record in studio
versions of these songs when I
girl arms we fell on hard times and we
lost our bright color you went to the
dogs and I lived by my
charm but we also knew that once we had
her on set Rachel really could do it
it's just so easy for her so it was just
great to be able to go in and do these
musical moments with her and just know
how comfortable she was in that
[Music]
zone she and Dave Cobb and the musicians
were really able to sort of capture that
kind of 1920s to 1930s sort of
appalachin quality you know that we all
loved and we were all aiming for and I
think it's a just a great ad element to
the movie and the
[Music]
story